Now that you've met Dr. Sun,
we will discuss one of his projects in more detail.
I appreciate his permission to use the graphics.
Children with complex chronic conditions accounted for
10.1% of pediatric admissions in 2006.
These admissions used around 25% of the pediatric hospital days,
accounted for some 40% of pediatric hospital charges,
caused over 40% of pediatric deaths,
and used 75% or more of technology assistance procedures.
Given the seriousness, and cost of care for these children,
understanding them and predicting changes in their condition is of great interest.
Here's an analytic pipeline for doing that.
First, we will focus on the feature construction phase.
Clinical classifications software CCS,
is a tool for clustering patient diagnoses and
procedures into a manageable number of clinically meaningful categories.
Here you see mapping the many ICD and CPT codes from EHR records to CCS.
As you see here 73 of
the CCS features have sufficient predictive power to be included in the final model.
Various approaches to prediction are tried,
and two random forest and gradient boost decision tree
produce the best results as you see here.
Random forest depends on the random selection of
both data and independent variables to create many decision trees.
The output is the mode or mean prediction of the individual trees.
Gradient boosting is a machine learning technique that produces a prediction model using
regression on an ensemble of weak prediction models, typically decision trees.
The graph is a Receiver Operating Characteristic (ROC) curve,
where each point represents
a sensitivity specificity pair corresponding to a particular decision threshold.
The area under the curve auc,
is equal to the probability that
a classifier will rank a randomly chosen positive instance,
higher than a randomly chosen negative one.